entreprendre au féminin 3e édition des
rencontres
kreactive à montigny le bretonneux
l'association de femmes chefs
d'entreprises étaient réunis pour
s'entraider et accompagner les porteuses
de projets l'occasion de s'intéresser à
la féminitude l'art de se servir de ses
attributs et les atouts féminins
féminitude c'est aussi le nom du jeu de
cartes que marianne est rare utilisent
pour le développement personnel de ces
climats le tirage que je fais très
souvent c'est un tirage en trois vers
une carte qui représente la personne une
carte qui va représenter plutôt le frein
c'est à dire ce qu'il faudrait
travailler ça une carte qui représente
le potentiel qui va permettre de
travailler sur le frein et de se
réaliser et de se retrouver d'être soi
même la solidarité féminine est le
maître mot de l'association cri active
c'est sur ce même concept qu'est né le
réseau social féminin
mais bonne copine points comme il ya
sept mois dix neuf mille inscrits qui
propose gratuitement aux autres femmes
leurs compétences
la fondatrice est en pleine levée de
fonds c'est pas évident d'être forcément
entendu crédible face à une assemblée
d'hommes un petit peu âgé environ 2
soixantaine d'années de moyenne d'âge et
d'être entendu prises au sérieux
bon après au bout de cinq minutes la
crédibilité se met en place mais il ya
un petit un petit temps on va dire de
suspicion voilà d'amusement va dire
l'autre difficulté gérer vie familiale
et vie professionnelle comme pour cette
créatrice maman de trois enfants
je crée c'est moins qu'il fabrique il
faut aussi en même temps
négocier avec les fournisseurs pour
obtenir les meilleurs prix etc
il faut aussi s'occuper de tout ce qui
est communication même si c'est mon
métier de départ il faut quand même
avoir le temps de le faire
on a fallu créer une boutique en ligne
tout ça ça prend du temps et puis en
même temps vendre être chef d'entreprise
pour résumer c'est surtout une question
de passion et d'investissement